tudo bem
boa tarde a todos a fotografia é da
mesma maneira eu escolhi propósito ali
fantasticamente com o chapéu na cabeça
com uma meta e aqui a apresentadora fez
um pergunta eu vou perguntar quem daqui
não leve guimarães um terço
quem aqui nunca ouviu falar em problemas
vamos falar das neblinas na perspectiva
de ganhar menos do que a raízes o que eu
vou dizer aqui não vais lá nada fica
precisamente o mesmo que é ninguém sabe
que são as colinas ok mas então vou
fazer o primeiro a primeira punição e
coerção festas e são festas de
estudantes
são festas estudantis de guimarães e
mais festas de estudantes das escolas
com notas de guimarães
vocês sabem e mais nos últimos anos tem
um polo seu domínio em que tem umas três
diferentes
acho que então umas gatas a qual não se
pode saber disso mas aqui vai falar das
disciplinas são as festas são nicolau e
portanto quando quando convidaram a
associação dos antigos estudantes e os
que mais tarde descobrimos casting do
qual faz parte e que gravaram para vir
aqui que tiveram medo de estar aqui e
ter uma cruz pode ficar alguma coisa eu
vou eu vou e perguntar e mandaram
entretanto por governança mandava um
papelinho como as diretivas do que podia
dizer que quer dizer o tempo que tenha
de 60 e 70
o documento dizia que eu vim aqui vender
uma idéia eu não vou vender e nenhuma e
perguntava ele é nova e não é
interessante sim realista talvez mas nem
sequer uma idéia e portanto o que é
estimado em r 60 anos aqui mas temos uma
coisa muito especial e que não havia uma
mensagem a desejar só percebeu os
melhoramentos observa mas quem fora
percebe
nós gostamos muito da cidade mas isso é
uma questão que já nasce connosco o o
sampaio antigo da república cujo pai
nasceu aqui
jenin e mais não sei mais dizer que está
uma espécie de patriotismo necessidade
de dizer o que quer
digamos diminuir uma espécie de
bairrismo rhmais tem esta tem este rosto
em ter coisas diferentes e com leve
vantagem de climas um espectro gama das
escolas secundárias do país é que é um
uma tradição única e se fosse hoje em
dia nós temos todos a igualdade
somos todos iguais só tem uma marca
telemóveis vocês verão um refugiado na
síria ou em dólar já tenho uma camisa do
chelsea ou o arsenal
estamos entendidos e ficamos todos
iguais globalmente ligados pelo mundo
mas o que nos faz de frente o que é mais
valia é termos as coisas realmente que
os outros não têm esse que mais tenha
sido ruim e acredita que elas podem ser
uma marca eu desconfio uma marca nas
costas e não vender não é ser a marca
não sabe não faço ideia mas agora o que
é que em relação às redes que estava
sendo projetado é fantástico
eu tenho que escrever cinco palavras se
não mesmo a palavra jogos - próprio
reise reise numa árvore é aquilo que
sustentar a árvore é de que o seguro das
reservas a descair do lado do outro lado
é que se alimenta
mas nós conhecemos uma árvore apreciamos
a árvore e não conseguimos saber que
seus responsáveis estão enterradas neste
caso das meninas é um caso isso mesmo
qualquer perspectiva histórica que tenha
havido qualquer estudo é certa nunca
consigo perceber como é que elas existem
porque elas existem e portanto o que é
que o que são as micro climas de colinas
só um pretexto
são três pessoas pesquisarem deus pelo
deus criou o mundo em 3 parece depois
que o homem porque a mulher mas depois
cria um dia para descansar porque é
passar para uma uma quebra que lhe abra
uma excepção e as festas se imaginar em
pelo menos mais longe das festas das
romarias que entrou água e aqui à volta
é a que mais evita precisamente para ser
uma opção precisarem passar em frente do
do normal ea depressão isso é a garra é
barulho
os amigos e ver os corpos recolhidos
também são criticados pessoas apanham
aceitou a vontade porque eu sou stefhany
eu não me sinto nem como entanto aqui a
prova que nem essa equação de nicolas
igual a a ave ambos é mentira que comigo
mas acho que antes de começar uma
fantástica apresentação que vai procurar
o que é de mais chuva não incluídas
neste momento é de colinas correm um
certo perigo que é obrigado a
popularização que tornará as neblinas
fora das mil colinas ser representadas
fora das nicolinas estou à vontade que
tudo nos vamos rodar em participar nelas
apenas os micro estiveram na abertura do
hospital na capital europeu 2012
estiveram também nuno concertos o dos
que vai ser só uma semana tiveram
conselho dos games
às vezes vão animar os jogos vitória e
agora temos um time zambo que é animar
montar novela com a lambada no fundo eu
embora eu estou no rio eu por acaso fui
smith parece que não apareço lá no rio
sempre foi justamente nessas gravações
fazer o que é que se por um lado se eu
tenho vontade de se transcender passar
para fora do gabinete disse nosso
ambiente mais pequena mas voltou a
correr o risco de se passarem o seu
tempo que eu não sei dizer que
aconteceram naquela naquela naquela
parte do ano e poderem de certa maneira
ser em serem melhorados vendidas como um
favorzinho a casinha fala essas coisas
todas e sempre buscando coisas têm que
se preocupar com isso e portanto o
levantamento de colinas é que as
neblinas existem há 335 anos pelo menos
mas nunca foram iguais mudaram sempre
porque a tradição só continuou as
pessoas reconhecerem mas foram adaptadas
adaptarem à aula ao aos tempos nós temos
em que participam
e agora eu como vêem o seu único trouxe
copianço também é uma festa de
estudantes tecnológica na época foi
assim que eu tenho curso 32 e portanto e
agora voltei muito pouco tempo mas tem
uns 20 minutos já gastei pai imutável
eu tenho 140 atletas vão passar que vai
ser reserva quatro segundos pessoal eu
não consigo ver tozzo e vou passar eu
fiz uma lista faz um tempo para eu
passar alguns slides
e vou explicar ano sendo que alguns
deles vão passar muito rapidamente peço
desculpas pois alguém quiser estou
interessado eu posso mandar este
powerpoint em português é que eu sou em
português bem positivos para todos sabem
que vamos começar então raízes se os
funcionários não funcionaram
estou há muito tempo também para um
passo acima há a tradição no sentido de
continuar a ser a musa que continuou
sendo sempre a mesma não sendo realmente
a mesma coisa importante é que este
trocou a tradição ea traição
já a a fazenda
hoje é o primeiro caso o chefe que
antecedeu faltou falou no pinheiro e
esse é que é o problema é que as festas
não só o pinheiro
o pinheiro é que o que é mais visível é
que reuniu milhares de pessoas na rua
que é uma coisa comercial eu lembro eu
tenho mais de 22 anos deu a vitória ao
pai não estava no ano dele eo meu
primeiro cd 1º etapa com muitas pessoas
estão já dizia que há 30 anos era mesmo
a hora e agora é uma coisa especial e
tem de maranhense nove bragança e também
de colegas não se podem reduzir o
pinheiro humanos deputado está hoje o
que é hoje em dia é esta é fenômeno de
massas dinheiro e os números das posses
que tem tido alguma algum
desenvolvimento
foi nestas provas fartas de coimbra
realização castelo soneca novela os
culpados além do cara a focalização
então é que os veículos mas eles têm
vários números nos vasos um carro com a
queima das fitas têm vários
acontecimentos mais ou menos uma semana
para quem não é do que mais recebe tem
vários números eo número inaugural é o
pinheiro por dois engenheiros têm
respostas brasileiras têm o pregão tenha
uma sozinhas têm na seção igual e
finalmente em um bairro tá quente para
expor o número se muito canônicos antes
das festas e também não vê nas suas
vendas nossa senhora conceição como
acontecem ao mesmo tempo o uniclinic
costumam participar também anotou a
placa diz um dos 11 7 11 12
muitas comissões consideram que um é o
primeiro dia que saem em uma atividade
oficial porque vão ao cemitério prestar
homenagem aos ícones franceses também é
preciso botar o plantel e rapidamente
fazer com ele já consegue com 17 tem
altos e baixos somos tão precisos aquela
melhora nem se tem uma coisa fantástica
que só acontece aqui é que reúne vários
novos na queima das fitas por exemplo os
vai já passaram e os novos aqui joédson
muito mais novos portanto é que é eu sou
novo
[Música]
nicolau fala aqui já vou suportar isso
na parte em que embaixo o juro pago nas
vestes eclesiásticas causaram
perturbações na vila em muitas
instâncias como estaria o arcebispo do
mesmo em carta em janeiro de 1975 quando
jovem e confusões em 1935
ok ok também com elas e agora foi para
trás da frança - o apartamento número
esse comportamento tem aqui uma
descrição mais ou menos cabelo que são
os números
pinheiro o trecho após que são ofertas
que os estudantes recebem que partilham
as pessoas
o pregão cama dela mas ela não tem este
feito em vários pontos do da cidade
as más línguas que são más mas assim foi
possível das meninas que estão nas
varandas e as danças que é uma espécie
de uma representação que já começou por
ser na rua e neste momento
atualmente é no teatro temos aqui a
comissão de festas ao i a nova bandeira
já gravava uma planilha com marcação e
os que trazem que deve
não tem canções incrível então aqui as
lanças com as fitas e decoradas por
namoradas pelas amigas onde expõe na
pontinha mas sozinhas entre as meninas
cá está um pinheiro
quem quiser saber mais coisas avaliou
erros rapidamente passar aí está uma
súmula de progressão igual
isso é sobre uma nação no clube estava
assim na linha é um personagem muito
conhecido aqui mais uma carreira
incluindo mas publicações
esta é a única obra literária do rio
brandão que o fluminense do do samba vai
vai a guimarães no início do século 20
em que fala embora no ninguém mais fala
pensamento só ele vai precisar de roupas
com tudo pra fora e descreve uma famosa
após ter a posse do cuse o concurso ea
nossa pateiro na rua nova que deu que
morreu em 1922 e que estão despediu
acuse mostrou eu mostrava o evento cujo
e tenha tanta fama que já na direção dos
mets foi na altura do do rio brandão
fizeram os nerds em que o instante lá o
curso demonstrou cunha neto coitado que
aquela era a demonstrar como o jornal
quando a boca era um boneco ok
finalmente a uma publicação está para
sair que é um estudo antropológico sobre
incluir na perspectiva da proximidade
das festas nicolinas candidatarem a
património mundial da humanidade
patrimônio imaterial tapui carlos prates
agora estão o técnico lino tem aqui os
pontos da cidade mais ou menos onde se
inclui nisso tem importância entrega e
está a gastar onde tudo começou
ao lado do paraguaio liberiana na igreja
nossa senhora da oliveira tem uma capela
que foi o estudante se levantaram em
1961 e nós a imagem de são nicolau que
está lá dentro
pensa que não é original só que vai
mostrar o século 18
naquela capela tem uma janela e acho que
o ponto tem mais é que era uma janela e
teve a porta pequena capela abrir para
dentro e capelas e levaram 300 anos em
1971 em paris decidiu desmontar a capela
que foi brilhante em cima e os
estudantes aqui mas não descansar
enquanto a capital não foi posta mas
depois das aulas
abrir para dentro da igreja vamos criar
aquela porta chamada porta do cavalo
portanto poderá entrar quem entrou no
lava que o lugar está o monumento único
leno feito por um único ano 80 por esta
e os animais é nicole foi incluído por
tanto fez e foi inaugurada em 2008 uma
breve história das micro ondas muito
rápida
já temos o o oe o gol lembrou a boa
vontade é fantástico maravilhoso está
sob qual o século 4º nasceu e viveu aqui
na ásia menor na na turquia é a primeira
na altura não é pretexto se você vê isso
o raulzinho drogas como o serviço foi
também havia muitos veículos eo ea
galera mesmo e posso dizer que tem um
fato histórico quando foi quando era
bispo
um dos papas chamava-se marcelo e 12 mil
discutiu no e eu a nova taxa não consigo
me sair é só você 10 em 1887
na média os marinheiros levarem itália
que é amigo de calcanhar na volta foram
buscar as relíquias o nicolau vizinhos
que são autênticas e fizeram uma
basílica onde estava não sabíamos se
voltava ou nicolau ea lei do mundo
ok só nicolau que está com vários
milagres citou três crianças que estavam
paralisadas desde venda
as meninas que queriam casar no fim do
túnel de slot nenhum quem na
prostituição história mesmo essa e
tamanho salvou vários bate boca de
patrono dos estudantes das prostitutas
na primeira ligação mas nem eles ok é
tão-só nicolau e sony paulo ao ver o
ministro
a unesco não precisa mais nada ok
a primeira floresta incluindo as muito
rapidamente
foi uma coisa que 150 dos 47 membros que
são documentos e lutarem com uma senhora
em 1656 perdoa aos estudantes os treinos
que fizeram na casa dela em 1945
terceira prova o estudante é curioso o
pleito o documento era pai filho tanto
que está já havia novos e velhos pai
feliz aqui o documento o documento em
português antigo grande assim e está a
prova quer forçar mais antigas 1945 os
estudantes tenham acesso à altura - do
corpo todo nove escolas que meninos e
meninos do coro é que no caminho da
goleada que é uma instituição muito
grande que muitos padres muitos
beneficiados do prior campo com muita
poeira e eram uma instituição que muitas
rendas e tenha meninos do coro e
aprendeu a ler em rendimentos ou até em
alguns de nós perseguimos todos deveriam
ser pagos outros problemas os chamados
estudantes e assim elton todos
estudantes mesmos documentos eram os
correios na confiança é só uma coisa é a
imagem de 45 precisamento camões
descrever um alto que o é o recebeu e um
dos personagens isto faz a melhor os
argumentos que moços estudo e professor
nicolau
então tem uma nota que diz que sabe que
o lauro tiveram seleção do seu patrono
portanto em portugal nem só no século 17
nicolau é uma planta antiga demais para
perceber que mais tinha tinha muito
rapidamente tinha cerca vai criar uma
muralha ea volta do castelo e no espaço
lux e tinha cerca nova fazia chegamos a
banda nova que fazia o contorno da
cidade é uma maneira é a razão primeira
capela precisa levantar a primeira los
no no total uma visão 3d grafia é
incrível conseguir sair com você todo
são três delas irá para quem o paga quem
não tem no sangue mais era uma cidade
molhada com várias todas nunca nós temos
quiserem da obra do symbian mas foram
foram foram de moedas todo mundo em
patrimônio e investimentos só existe um
padrão muralha que ela era
o paço dos duques na região norte
sampaio eo motor não é um canalha um
motor ou lista aqui nasceu portugal anda
um bocado alguém que traga uma atrofia e
falhou o poder de meter uma fotografia
muito bem tarde mas se você tem um
estudante que estava faltando 30 do
século 17 da oliveira noiva ainda temos
algumas casas a pedradas temos aqui a
pedra capela que me espera fundamental
são nicolau a 1962 capela fotografias
olhos tentando da capela aquela que
existia nos anos 70 que foi e que foi
demolida está o compromisso de
manutenção i love 1691 crítico
estudantes podem fazer a dança como
elvis presley ganhar dinheiro gastar 990
em um aqui está uma filosofia autênticas
doutoral do século 17 que temos ali
gostoso tá toda esta tua primeiro aqui
mais próxima é o que os dias aqui nasceu
portugal que é toda a família já não te
amo estou eu disser uma palavra uma
bomba
temos a leitora atuando na porta do
milan
isto é se davam por aqui fóruns para que
fora o primeiro por cabo foi a primeira
notícia do pinheiro é meu eu vou falar
em factos reais
primeiro você fala do piano 1822 a
primeira notícia sobre o emprego é de
1817 e explicavam dias no fim marcianos
o tal amor do mundo tóquio antes havia
um gosto melhor não é uma sozinhas
o primeiro desde 1858 aposta do concurso
é o curso e mostrou como já falei algo
caso as sessões com a krona se uma
seleção de estudantes que foi feito nos
acusando a usar só usar constantes quer
por aí buscar outros estudantes eram
mais uma sessão lá e queremos assim
estamos apostando em marcas muito
rapidamente autoral no século 19 está
velho e não 65 estão mais tranquilas foi
um custo muito importante oliveira estão
eles o nicolau bueno sabe qual foi o
efeito em 1850 e 58 pessoas aluno vezes
não sabemos que fez a música em duas
cantaram em uníssono pouco não esquenta
ao campo da feira em 1958 e mais em 1960
outra vez em 1970 passou pelo ine é e
depois têm estas são imagens de manhã
altura uma força que não estava em seus
games
a moeda está outra altura e em 1995 em
1995 é ao famoso renascimento das festas
é uma data muito importante com as
cheias que estão aqui muitos padres
pastores alexandre sampaio têm ligado
para uma cultura e as pessoas são
estudantes uma fotografia dos olhos 20
provas os estudantes já tinham esta
estranha coreografia do dom barreto
frisou na cabeça a quem isto é uma
abertura do do programa 1995 está uma
delícia questão o programa das festas em
eu não tenho tempo não estava
maravilhosa pra vocês lêem mas não temos
tempo e no século 20 é e em 1904 e
vimaranenses onu maneira absurda do
domicílio no porto como o jovem estreou
pela primeira vez festas nicolinas todas
as festas até altura eram as substâncias
são nicolau o futebol e só depois deste
pregão em que ouvir a música da festa
incluindo passaram a ser conhecidas
pelas festas nicolinas sofre tanto no
século 20 é que sou chamado de colinas
está estas fotografias são mesmo
fotografias tanto no centro do século 20
é um a um
pegar um perto da ue na roupa você
observa
a oi também na rua gil vicente o pregão
em 71 fez de coração da muralha
a lei 11 usar o senhor tem uma máscara e
é que uma distribuição mais sozinhas
também em 1920 ok é que a porta do liceu
coisa é a câmara na altura venceu em 927
a saída já falei nas menininhas
não posso falar mais é que o fundador da
nossa seleção e aqui o único no more
original era chegar um personagem do
século 20 é muito importante nós nas
festas natalinas é que essa nação que é
preciso mandar todos almada ali na rua
na na rua da rainha onde está a casa da
minha mãe está a bandeira não mostrar a
casa da minha mãe tempo bandeira está a
bandeira original da academia dos seus
animais que precisamos que andré 927
feita pois tudo incluindo professor
desenhos é de pina
esta é a produção em engordava assim são
personagens são personagens incluindo 78
muito importante e assim não sei quem é
estamos nervosas e este é o sangue reino
eu sei que vem já está entre nós nem
investidores de que os problemas legais
e assim ataque as tiro nem eu preciso
acessando e além com todo o gosto que os
meus graça
ok pronto e finalmente só para matar
mandar um tamanho exemplo um vídeo seu
pai o velho pra ninguém falar com bosco
eo vídeo não se encontravam os gráficos
depois chegava ao fim engolir uma espada
e não consigo fazer isso e então eu
queria falar sobre essas coisas porque
os nem cuida da minha função passa
também a ser um combinado de todas as
disciplinas
nesse sentido eu vou ser um complemento
claro que ele tem cinco minutos nilmar
recebeu o vídeo é uma coisa fantástica
depois quero ver pagam cinco euros cada
um eu posso expostos aos mesmos cinco
minutos mas fazer o quê
essas mudanças na inclinação a prova que
a tradição se mantém mudando as mudanças
que se faziam um emmy no século 17
não tem nada a ver com as danças que se
faziam já fizeram apresentações musicais
que treinos em casa nobre na rua no
século 19 e os favores que é um
espetáculo ganhamos no esteiro ou mais
ou menos um mês inteiro no teatro com as
pessoas personagens principais
o afonso agora numa são duas estátuas
que temos aqui em mais o camareiro outro
ão e um solo igual todos o espetáculo
tem outras coisas mas são as duas
personagens âncora estou aqui tá aqui é
a roma o camareiro que é a ideia das
minorias novas melhorias
afonso henriques eo e portanto o relógio
para um paiol posso falar aonde eu vou
só rematar pode dizer que o guimarães
tem coisas de frente dos outros dos
outros dos outras cidades que quiserem e
as nicolinas é um bem que temos que
preservar nunca deixando cair a tradição
mas também sabendo reinventar e rico
cenário pensar e portanto que eu posso
dizer é que estamos na melhor cidade do
mundo e temos as melhores festas muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]